powers won't work fine either
you must have blasted us with something
what the hell are you
I am your destiny hey everybody this is
gonna be my flash episode 13 video I
think by the end of the episode we
probably all had a pretty good idea of
how team flash is gonna defeat the
thinker in addition to what's avatar
told us last season like we already know
the mechanism with which he defeats the
thinker but I think all that stuff with
his wife at the end I think we're all
probably in agreement that she is the
way the team flash beats the thinker it
was just a toss-up as to which one of
them would go a little bit crazier in
the thinker singing through Becky's body
I'm going out of my mind is more of him
literally going crazy as he pushes his
consciousness into more and more bodies
that's why Barry was talking about him
absorbing all their powers so let's do
the top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs
and there is a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just share
the video using those tools on the watch
page I'll announce a new winner at the
end of this starting with number 10 the
Stargate crossover so if you guys didn't
watch Stargate Atlantis Carson Beckett
from that show was guest starring is
this old friend of Ralph's when he was
still kind of a dirtbag and let people
down
they eventually brought it back around
by halfway through the episode like look
you're not as bad as you think you are
that's basically the cliff notes of that
storyline Ralph's didney needs to
realize that he's a good person and he
has value to team Flash and they
actually end up using his ability to get
Barry at a prison number nine biggest
question I got hands down a little while
ago was how did he turn himself into a
black person though how did he change
his skin pigment give me all your tropic
thunder jokes the science of it seems a
little fast and loose it's not an
ability that he has in the comics so
this is something new to the TV show but
I think as long as they're consistent
with it I'm totally fine with him being
able to change himself to look like
anything the really important thing
about it though is is that they remind
you that he's not really good at it yet
so he can lose his cohesion like it sort
of breaks down after a time so I think
it'll be fine as long as the writers are
consistent with Ralph's level of ability
with that skill but just
remember HR like pretending to be other
people dying in place of other people so
number eight that twist at the end of
the episode where they look at Ralph and
he's like why do you have the look on
your face like you're looking at a dead
man almost as if he's foreshadowing his
own death on the TV show I think it
depends on what they want to do with the
character next season I don't think
it'll be the exact same twist as HR
because part of the reason why we're
going with a non speedster villain is
because we've done that so many times
so to recycle the big twist from last
season would be even worse than that
so I think that's the main reason why we
shouldn't worry too much that they're
gonna do the HR thing with his character
so it doesn't mean that he's completely
safe but I do think that the actor likes
being on the show and all the other
actors like him in real life so it just
everybody wants him to come back so we
probably won't find out too much about
that till the end of the season because
we thought that tom Felton was gonna
come back but then the producers are
like yeah he didn't want to do another
season with us so they just had to write
him off of the show but number seven
Barrie MacGyver versus way out of the
cell they all escape and you sort of tee
up the bekkie storyline like I you know
I don't want to hurt people I want to be
a good person so I'm just gonna stay
right here but they just made the twist
at the end of the episode that much more
heartbreaking they're just trying to set
the thinker up as being a really bad
person that you definitely want them to
kill the Escape from Alcatraz the
Shawshank Redemption may call the Prison
Break jokes that you can think of like
we literally have the Prison Break
actors on the air over us like when we
come back on legends of tomorrow captain
cold is still on the TV show but he's
not here forever
and we also find out - why the thinker
doesn't care about the other metas
because they say that peekaboo and
weather wizard are still locked up at
iron Heights so there are other metas
that Barry's locked up but number six
the thinker versus his wife and the new
chair so she modifies the chair remember
she's an engineer she builds things like
Cisco builds things she built the
thinking cap she'll also probably wind
up building the neural inhibitor for
team flash but she uses that song to
block the thinker out of her mind
because she just doesn't completely
trust him even though it is her husband
the way it sounds like they're
explaining him going out of his mind the
way the song says this is because his
powers his mind are expanding to such a
level that the person that he was is
getting sublimated and now he's just
turning into this amalgam person this
crazy God like being that no longer
cares about the things that he cared
about when he was human and primarily
his wife so his wife is sort of picking
up on that like hey wait a minute
because she's all about the
enlightenment but now it sounds like the
thinker is just becoming more and more
inhuman to make a Marvel pun but you
obviously saw what the upgraded chair
can do at the end of the episode where
it literally just allows him to spread
his consciousness and control the other
metas so now it's sort of like this hive
mind situation and there's no freewill
about it number five this was a bit of a
surprise the word an outing Barry is the
flash to the other bus metas and they
pretty much all turn on him with the
exception of Becky there was that funny
moment where she was using her powers to
give everybody else bad luck so it's a
nice twist so hopefully that'll come
back around by the end of the season
like you want to think that some of the
medes aren't gonna be totally evil like
Becky and elongated man or two of the
bus metas and they seem like really good
people so maybe they'll find some
hilarious way to bring that back around
as they try to defeat the thinker at the
end of the season still not a huge fan
of am units character so the less they
use her in the episode the better but
they did reference a future episode
where there is a bit of a metahuman
team-up that she puts together and I
think it'll probably involve whether
wizard some of the other metas that
Barry said are locked up in iron Heights
but that the thinker does not care about
he only cares about the bus metas so any
of the Rogues that are still around and
available will be guest starring in an
episode it's sort of like a team-up
situation and it'll sort of be the TV
shows version of her comic book teams
that she had during geoff johns thinker
art but again just remember that there's
this whole thing about metahumans using
their powers for good so maybe a lot of
the medes that barry has helped lock up
over the past couple of seasons will
help him out temporarily the way Captain
Cold went from being a straight-up bad
guy to helping Barry out every once in a
while between big heists that he would
pull like he still does bad things but
every once in a while he does help out
team flash but number three big twist
they killed the warden off I was
actually pretty surprised by this
because he's a relatively big comic book
character and iron heist is a pretty big
location so it is fine that they got rid
of him as long as they don't completely
dump iron Heights is a location for
story because you have so many different
metahumans locked up in there that I
think they'll go back there again this
season like I said with the Amunet
character and the rogue team-up but it's
such a rich place for story that
hopefully
find a way to use it during season five
without completely recycling a lot of
the story that they've done this season
number two of course is the thinker
absorbing all their powers and then
later his wife having the second fight
with him it all just for shadows her
turning on him later this season it's
just a question of when it's going to
happen in what's going to set her off
like it's just like a slow descent into
oh my god you're not my husband you're
completely crazy maybe the plane goes
off the rails whatever it is she helps
build the neural inhibitor cap and then
they take the thinker down she becomes
the reason why they're able to defeat
the thinker but number one was sort of
the funny twist at the end of the
episode where they get Barry off using
elongated man's powers I love the
thinker's wife to she's just like I have
no way of explaining this I don't know
what's going on here and they play it
mostly for comedy but you're like wow
this actually stuck Barry is out of
prison and it seems like he's not going
back anytime soon hopefully Ralph gets
better at that ability because I have a
feeling that the police will want to
follow up with him like DeVoe you're not
dead what's going on please explain how
this all happened he's gonna have to
continue pretending to be the old
version of the thinker but like this end
at the end of the episode now they know
that DeVoe wants to take the powers of
all the bus metas so next week's episode
will be them trying to help out one of
the other bus metas and they are sort of
circling back around to some comic book
storyline so trial of the flash the way
that they solve that is because they
found out that abracadabra was
pretending to be the reverse-flash
so Ralph's pretending to be devote was
sort of a twist on that so they did
bring it back around to comic book trial
of the flash as well as the Geoff Johns
thinker arc where he's sort of spreading
his consciousness digitally to other
people now the way that that worked was
more of a matrix storyline so the TV
shows version is a little bit different
from that but he's effectively taking
over other people's minds and it just
gets worse and worse eventually it
becomes the entire city so just let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite part of the episode and what do
you think is going to cause the
thinker's wife to turn on him like what
will finally be the domino that tips
them all over
couple big references they made Cisco
dropped an it movie reference with the
painting that comes to life Caitlin is a
frosty Oprah now giving people life
advice and she also references that
sabotage storyline her example of
letting her friends down was them sort
of joking about how killer frost turned
on iris and helped murder
her on a dime the actors explained that
they still never got an explanation from
the writers why killer frost just turned
on a dime like it was kind of a funny
story point like why would she just
immediately turn on iris the person that
she'd been friends with for so long so
every once in a while there are some
inconsistencies in the way they write
the characters but what will happen is
is they just announced that the game of
Thrones producers Dan and Dave are doing
a new Star Wars trilogy that's going to
be a period piece set during a different
time period than present-day meaning
it's probably going to be set during the
past so I'll do video about that next as
well as another Avengers video so leave
all your requests in the comments below
but remember the flash is on break for a
couple weeks I will do flash videos next
week though so plenty of bonus videos
happening no worries congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner creo pass
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round in this video announce the winner
when I post new DC obviously flash
trailer tomorrow click here to learn
about the Titan season 1 premiere in my
new wally west video and you can click
here to rewatch that Avengers trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight